is this your only date this week yeah I
feel honored thank you thank you so much
that was a lie I'm Lauren I'm Rachel we
are here on a date first date blind date
and since that's not awkward enough
we've decided to also like put a little
lie detector spin on it yeah we haven't
even started my heart rate is already
through the roof
I think first dates are kind of
nerve-wracking in general especially a
blind one where you don't know anything
about the person that you're meeting
this is my first blind date ever yeah I
guess I'm most nervous about this lie
detector portion of it cuz usually on
first dates you know you just not lie
but you like put your best foot forward
a little bit might exaggerate some
things and now some guys gonna like call
me out of my
all right Rachel first question here are
you currently dating multiple people no
that's true I've never really like dated
multiple people in a row I've been kind
of like sort of seeing people yeah
you're serial monogamous yeah and I'm
also someone who's just like single a
lot and I'm like I'm too busy to date is
this your only date this week yeah
I feel honored thank you thank you so
much that was a lie
oh okay is there someone you're hoping
to go on a date with usually I go on a
first date and then it's like I'm like
when's the second date away okay and
waste no time I like it have you left a
long-term relationship within the last
six months no crew have you been in a in
any long-term relationship yeah more
than six months are you still in touch
with your last ex no that's true I feel
like a relationship when it plays out
its course it's done and I don't think
it like serves anyone anymore
so you've never gone back to an ex once
and then end it even worse than after
that I learned my lesson are you so
attracted to any of your accents no you
need to find people attractive like
physically because no likely attractive
no romantic feelings yeah are you
attracted to any of your friends
yeah true are these friends you want
would like date realistically in the
future I don't know it's a new friend
and I just don't know I'm like are we
friends do you think I'm more attractive
in real life than my profile pic yes
true okay I feel like that's a like a
double-sided question through this thing
like oh like you look bad on Instagram
you know some people can like camp it up
on Instagram especially on Instagram you
got filters you got all these like
Photoshop things you know but have you
gotten lucky within the last month
whatever lucky means to you
no no crew like March was busy it was
like being a caretaker for my grandma
her boyfriend while he went on a cruise
do you think you'll get lucky tonight no
boy I don't know I just want to be clear
I didn't write this you think this is
going well yeah okay true that's good
have you already made up your mind about
whether you want to see me again yeah
don't wait screw what it so that was all
the questions that were given to me but
I just want a dovetail back on that last
question so you said you already made up
your mind what was your mind made up to
I'd like to see you again this is going
so well no it's my turn to ask the
question are you currently dating
multiple people yes true how many people
it's like how many oh man no I'd say
like some of them I haven't met yet in
person I just like have been talking on
like apps and stuff like oh so we
haven't actually gone on a date yet are
we dating yet technically I don't know
if you're not sure how many people
you're dating let's use the lie detector
are you dating upwards of five people
no definitely wouldn't say upwards of
five that's a lie upwards of five then
I'm just nervous and sweating now moving
on is this your only date this week yes
[Music]
the crew have you left a long-term
relationship within the last six months
not within the last six months crew are
you still in touch with your ex yes girl
friendly yes yeah yeah like we're we're
friends she was my first like long-term
relationship and in that we kind of like
developed a really good friendship and I
think a long way I just realized we were
maybe better friends then as a couple so
we've held on to that are you / yes okay
are you still attracted to any of your
exes yes true okay like you said you
know like you you date people and for
some I think the attraction still kind
of stays at least in the physical sense
are you attracted to any of your friends
no no I'm not true if I'm attracted to
someone I usually try to just go for it
and not get friend-zoned first I guess
do you think I'm more attractive in real
life and then my profile page yes cool
you seemed cute from the profile picture
obviously you're definitely more
beautiful in person
do you think you'll get lucky tonight no
I try to keep my expectations to a
minimum so I don't get disappointed but
I didn't go into this thinking I don't
get lucky tonight so have you already
made up your mind about whether or not
you want to see me again yeah true what
is yes or no you want to see me again
yes I would like to see you again true
agree on things we're all out of
questions but I can ask some of my own
oh okay I'm more nervous now do you
normally get lucky on the first date no
not normally I have like before I can
have a crew it's not like the standard
have you gotten like a first step or so
are you would you do that after a first
date anymore no okay no fair enough I
think it's an interesting way to get to
know someone I
do you think it's it's still kind of
awkward having the lie-detector aspect
part of it but it does cut through all
the bull I would love to go on a second
date I would like to as well I think you
got it world
[Music]